retour en france maintenant avec les
salariés des aéroports de paris en
partie en grève depuis hier les
syndicats dénoncent une révision des
contrats de travail avec des baisses de
rémunération à part la réduction de
certaines primes
la direction campe sur ses positions et
la grève pourrait bien durer on en parle
justement avec notre reporter katia
technique en direct de l'aéroport de
roissy charles de gaulle et ketchup et
cnic bonjour alors qu'attendre de cette
deuxième journée de mobilisation quel
est le programme aujourd'hui
mais aujourd'hui les salariés sont venus
en nombre la mobilisation est montée
d'un cran par rapport à la journée
d'hier puisque les salariés adp sont
entrés au niveau de l'embarquement
qu'ils bloquent depuis 9h ce matin au
bord des passagers qui étaient vraiment
médusé interloqué qui ont été re goûter
pour une partie qu'on terminal 2f qui
s'est retrouvé saturé
hélas les forces de l'ordre qui encadre
les salariés quittent d'ailleurs pas
passer à une vitesse supérieure de leur
côté ces guerres qui ne bouge pas en
tout cas ils ont enlevé un petit couloir
et des passagers viennent au compte
gouttes
en tout cas ces salariés aujourd'hui
sont venus très déterminé de tous les
syndicats fo cgt unsa cfdt
ils sont bien les tambours des confettis
des cornes de brume ils applaudissent
ils sont extrêmement bruyant pour peser
sur le rapport de france contre leur
direction une direction dont ils
contestent le plan d'adaptation des
contrats dits le plan pacte qui baissent
en moyenne de 7% leur salaire et les
économies sont réalisées sur les
indemnités kilométriques par exemple et
les heures majorées
il dénonce ces baisses de salaires
d'autant qu'il vient par exemple j'ai
plein de cas particulier les parents
isolés ou encore les coupes chez adp
il ya énormément de couple au sein des
entreprises et donc
si leurs salaires baissent ce sera pour
eux la double peine sujet de la
mobilisation d'aujourd'hui je vous
proposais d' écouter quand délégué force
ouvrière
pour ce qui nous concerne la grève se
poursuit
elle est très bien suivi et vous voyez
que autour de vous que la grève elle est
suivie par l'ensemble des personnels
qu'ils soient agents d'exécution cadre
il y en a ras-le-bol pour que la
direction retire et regarder la
détermination autour de vous allez on
est les attaques
grâce aux rapports de force finalement
une délégation de quelques syndicats a
été reçue par la direction ne sait pas
encore où ça en est et ici les
syndicalistes attendent le retour de
cette délégation pour décider de la
suite à donner à la mobilisation
aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup katia technique en direct
donc de l'aéroport de roissy charles de
gaulle on reviendra vers vous bien sûr
lors de nos prochaines éditions